thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode hey crazies in a previous
video I explained that electric charge
was a coupling property it measures how
linked or coupled a particle is to the
electromagnetic field
this connection explains why electric
charge is conserved and frankly why the
electromagnetic field even works but to
understand it we're gonna need a little
quantum mechanics this episode was made
possible by generous supporters on
patreon
okay so the ultimate question we're
trying to answer what this video is why
is charge conserved but we're gonna need
to answer a few other questions first
this video comes to you in four parts
part 1 what do we mean by charge charge
is a fundamental property of particles
these are the elementary particles some
of them have negative charge some of
them have positive charge and some of
them are electrically neutral they can
combine to make composite particles
which can also carry electric charge you
just total up the charge of the
elementary particles they're made of
charge is just a number but aren't
particles like electrons also called
charges yes but that's just people being
lazy I don't know if you knew this but
humans are lazy when we call something
like an electron a charge that's just
short for charged particle
I've ominously been guilty of it too but
but for this video I'm gonna be more
careful than that in this video the word
charge will always refer to the number
not the particle part two what does it
mean for something to be conserved a
conserved quantity is just a number that
stays the same over time kind of like
how environmental conservation is all
about keeping the environment the same
notice theorem tells us that all
conserved quantities are the result of
some invariance or symmetry in the
universe if you can vary one condition
like where or when an event takes place
and that event plays out exactly the
same way it's called an invariance
neuters theorem says there must be a
conserved quantity no exceptions
linear momentum goes with location
invariance energy goes with time
invariance angular momentum goes with
rotational invariance my stress goes
with Quarantine invariance every in
variance has a conserved quantity part
three what invariance is causing charge
to be conserved in invariance in the
electromagnetic interaction charged
particles interact electrically and
magnetically they do this over seemingly
empty space but not instantaneously this
leads us to infer that maybe the space
between them is filled with something
something that carries the interaction
between those particles whatever that
something might be we have several ways
of modeling it we could imagine it as
some kind of field of forces the
electric field exerts a force on charged
particles the magnetic field does the
same thing but only if the particles are
moving
however forces are not the only way to
look at a situation sometimes energy and
momentum can give you a deeper insight
this is something called the electric
potential it's a way for charged
particles to provide energy to each
other
is there a magnetic potential yeah there
is it fulfills a similar purpose but for
momentum instead of energy it's a way
for charged particles to exchange
momentum with each other fields are fine
if you're working with forces but
potentials are better if you're working
with energy and momentum you know things
that tend to obey conservation
principles and as it turns out the
fields are invariant under certain
changes in the potentials this is how
they're related
he is the electric field B is the
magnetic field V is the electric
potential and a is the magnetic
potential the potentials determine the
fields
we're not uniquely say we take this
electric potential and shift all the
values by some constant the values might
be different but the changes across
space are still the same those changes
are just the electric field it was
unaffected by the shift in the potential
that shift isn't even limited to
constants it can vary across space and
time it works as long as the shift is a
rate of change across space in the
magnetic potential and a rate of change
across time in the electric potential
these fields are defined by these
potentials but also these potentials or
these potentials this F could be any
function of space and/or time that F is
something we call a gauge so this
invariance is called gauge invariance
that gauge could be anything it's
completely random or is it part 4 what
does an invariance in a field have to do
with charged particles this is where
quantum mechanics becomes important
little particles like electrons are
inherently quantum mechanical they're
not really tiny spheres we might not
know exactly what they are but they're
definitely not tiny versions of this
their behavior is described by waves of
probability like this one that describes
location these waves are completely
unobservable but we do get to see the
square of those waves if the wave looks
like this its square looks like this we
call it a probability density because
the area underneath tells us the
probability that something will happen
another nice feature of these waves is
that they have something called global
phase invariance
what's a phase it's just what we call a
shift in a wave it's not that big of a
deal here's the basic sine wave it's
exactly where it's supposed to be which
means it has a phase of zero the size of
any shift in that waves is called the
phase if we're talking about a quantum
wave for something like an electron then
a phase shift will not affect the waves
probability density the likelihood of
finding the electron in any particular
place is unaffected by the shift if that
phase shift is the same everywhere in
space and time we call it a global phase
shift the real properties of all quantum
particles are invariant under this kind
of shift in the language of quantum
mechanics we'd write that like this
where fee is the phase angle inside is
the quantum wave the complex squares of
these two waves are the
same which means the probabilities are
the same so is there anything like that
that only applies to charged particles
yeah there is local phase invariants
that's when a different phase shift
occurs at different places in different
times without some kind of control it
would take a wave that looks like this
and turn it into one that looks like
this it's a complete mess but not if we
can tweak Schrodinger's equation in just
the right way that's the equation that
governs what the particles wave looks
like in space and how it evolves over
time however this form of it the one
that everybody knows only applies to
electrically neutral spin zero particles
luckily we can fix it
with the electromagnetic potentials
remember those the adjusted Schrodinger
equation looks like this
yes it's nastier but it finally applies
to charged particles with nonzero spin
it still doesn't apply to relativistic
particles but that's a topic for another
day
though oddly enough this adjustment does
fix our phase shift problem the local
phase shift turned our particles wave
into this but the electromagnetic
interaction turns it back into this the
electromagnetic potentials give charged
particles local phase invariance if a
particle has electric charge then it
interacts with the electromagnetic field
and has local phase invariance all three
of these statements are 100% equivalent
charge particles have local phase
invariance
neutral ones don't no exceptions but
that middle statement that the one about
interacting with the electromagnetic
field it's the key to this whole thing
do you remember that seemingly random
gauge function from earlier well it's
the same as the quantum phase of the
particle the gauge shift in the field is
the phase shift of the particle boom so
wait why is charge conserved because of
an invariance in the electromagnetic
interaction charged particles are
inextricably linked to the
electromagnetic field quantum mechanics
requires this that link is what it means
to be electrically charged any
invariance in the field
we'll be coupled with an invariance in
the particles and according to neuters
theorem any invariance results in a
conserved quantity that conserved
quantity is electric charge
so hopefully that ties up all the loose
ends
I'm sure you'll let me know in the
comments if I forgot to mention
something thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy many people are on the
lookout for online math and science
resources right now if you are - you
should check out brilliant brilliant is
a problem-solving based website and app
with a hands-on approach with over 60
interactive courses in math science and
computer science whether you're a
student looking to get ahead a
professional brushing up on cutting-edge
topics or someone who just wants to use
this time to understand the world better
brilliant could be the resource you're
looking for check out their trigonometry
course with quizzes on waves and phase
shifts or go back to the basics with
their mathematical fundamentals course
brilliant helps you achieve your goals
in stem starting with one small
commitment to learning and building up
to long term challenge and growth if
this sounds like a service you'd like to
use go to brilliant org slash science
asylum today the first 200 subscribers
will get 20% off an annual subscription
Feinstein 100 brought up an old quote
time is what keeps everything from
happening at once
yes wheeler said that but technically he
was quoting an old short story from 1921
called the time professor the more you
know anyway thanks for watching